this life is an ongoing train that no
one can seem to jump off I honestly
don't know how I handle everything I
mean having a great team great time
management but I always say my vocation
is my vacation and I've never really
felt like I worked the day in my life
because I love what I do so I just
grateful for the opportunity to to live
the life that I live so I'm always going
I'll never turn off and when I do turn
off it's like man I want to I want to do
more there's so much more than I could
be doing I feel like I'm always playing
catch-up so I think that that's the
drive that's the motive right you know I
feel like there's this ticking clock
that I'm up against and I'm like you
know I got to get as much in as I
possibly can
I'm late I'm behind so you know from
from films to music to TV to just so
many projects I don't feel like I want
to offer up and get the opportunity to
do and I'm doing it so it's a blessing
that door right there is my gym this is
one of the main studio rooms Edit Bay
arcade a candy store I do my podcast
upstairs my office is upstairs
you know we pull in and we get to it
daily I like dark my morning starts
every single day about 4:45 really
leaving home around 5:00 something and
getting to the radio station right after
that and that's where so you got to turn
it on you know regardless of how you
feeling you know even having lupus odd
to check in with my doctor's to make
sure you know whatever is attacking my
body that my immune system can handle
eating but uh you know like I said I
checked them on my doctor we good now so
today it's just really just like any
other day
that guy radio used to be just a voice
but you know a lot of the stuff that
goes viral is our digital content
everything everything's about a viral
moment now so here's what it is you know
I feel like there's those military
advertisements where they say you know
I'll do more before 9 a.m. than most
people do it all day and that's a
definitely a true statement because
we're entertaining for hours in the
morning and doing everything from
serious topics to to money prizes and
games so interviewers got a chance to
hang out with money bag yo and play him
and connect for that he requested you
know you have a street rapper request to
play a game with you is not that doesn't
happen every day
and then you know wrapped that up in the
morning head straight to where we are
here to kind of go over office things
and kind of check in with with the staff
and then from here we're gonna hit the
town and talk everything from my new
talk show to my current you know
nationwide tour were wiling out that we
got a hit so it'll be a good journey
today
Live Nation locked it in Wilin out or
things are going extremely well can't
complain always good to walk out of a
meeting full of good news
we got work to do
[Music]
you know your kids ask you what color
did you go to well and then you know you
start making up little excuses and stuff
especially when you're encouraging them
to you know take their academic career
seriously I was like you know what I
think that's that boy that's that
emptiness you know I accomplished a lot
in my life but I truly learned that you
know education is true success in a
wealthy and really just that process I
remember I was talking to I think it was
like Charlemagne a guy and he kind of
asked a similar question I was like we
all read books ones that last time you
study you know like you can't you you a
part of your brain you kind of turn off
after you leave school you find yourself
in different circles and it's not like
oh I'm no presh alone I'm in academia
now it's just more like now it's like
I'm I'm intrigued I'm filling a vessel
that kind of was capped so you know I
last kind of schooling I was a teenager
so to be able to jump back into it it
just was it felt really good and I
remember making that decision you know
2016 of like I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
just go for it I'm with no I'm gonna see
what happens and you know look up to
four years flew by the depending on how
early I'll and I get a opportunity to
just refresh and get it all together but
finish up homework
and then get to campus normally about
7:45 and then that's when we leave
campus to go to the facility of
incarceration usually it's the DC jails
this semester it's been a a youth
facility which is a little more
laid-back so it's probably about 15
minutes away from campus and that's kind
of where I feel like that's not only is
it a class but it's also you know
philanthropic in a sense where is this
activism dealing with youth I don't know
it's it's fulfilling in so many ways
it's one of the first classes that I get
to co-facilitate with my professor dr.
Muhammad but so I'm like I'm instructing
but I'm also learning at the same time
but at the time I'm hopefully feeding
and pouring into young people I'll do
good you see
I officially established incredible as a
company in 2009 before that I had
compartmentalized my business in such a
way to where I had like a record label
that was called can't eyeball and a
television production company called mr.
Renaissance and my films were Nick
Cannon Films and I at one point in 2009
I was like yeah I want to create a
multimedia conglomerate a space you know
I kind of liking it at the time to a
company like a Sony that could do
everything from electronics and you know
create devices that you consume content
on and then actually create content and
then it just even grew from that point
when you think of you know getting into
the consumer electronics business in a
real way in 2010 is when I you know
established and created incredible
headphones but then at the same time
still having incredible the label and
management as well as the film and
television components and even the
touring business and everything that we
have established to this day so and and
now you know wearing the Bluetooth
speakers and even wanting to branch that
out but again our core business is
entertainment so and I feel like that's
the nucleus of everything
so this is my mobile office as I call it
my home away from home
obviously studio for access to you know
conference calls to me my life is all
about time management I mean I love cars
I love to drive we're doing a workday in
the mobile office in the background so
whether I'm cleaning up a track with
them you know writing a script doing
homework I get an extra couple of hours
where everybody else is focused on
driving you know I have my own driver
and I get opportunity to take every
phone call and kind of lock in on emails
and all the communication so I would
encourage any entrepreneur businessman
that could afford a more mobile office
you'll get so much more out of your day
to be able to operating something like
this and then you get accustomed to this
is the incredible mobile office I think
at a certain time the slash is mattered
but I think to be successful in this
business you got to be versatile and I
think that goes leaving all the way back
to the days you know Sinatra and you
know Judy Garland you even before then I
mean when you think of what you can go
all the way to vaudeville to Broadway
like think of when Broadway was
initially created not only did you have
to be able to act sing dance play
instruments but you also had to be able
to be a entrepreneur in that sense of
like you had to promote yourself you had
to get out there and and figure out how
to market you know whatever play or
whatever you were putting forth so I
still got one more classic trying to get
to my final exam in enough time nosed
colleagues like now that goes trying to
rush to another building all the way
across the yard we walk this a famous
how're y'all right now so to be able to
you know make you just did what uh how
you doing man good to see you pleasure
pleasure how you doing I can see is a
great word
probably
the most important words when you think
about life in general like what's the
whole purpose of us being here when
we're no longer here how will we be
remembered mine is simple though smiles
I feel like I get to help provide them
and I think I'll probably be remembered
for being a guy no matter what I was
going through I was always smiling so
yeah after I roll in this exam i'ma
catch y'all back your la maybe Atlanta
maybe New York it's all over we'll go to
my exam hopefully we all fail we getting
out of here in May so it's gonna be good
you